bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur soucier de gosse
[Musique]
je suis très heureuse de vous retrouver
aujourd'hui pour une nouvelle vidéo qui
va prolonger l'esprit d'halloween qui
est déjà bien loin derrière nous qu'on
se le dise aujourd'hui nous allons
parler des sorcières quand je vous dis
sorcière vous pensez peut-être à
l'affreuse belle mère de blanche neige
ou encore à la belle n'est inquiétante
maléfique dans la belle au bois dormant
vous la voyez d'ailleurs peut-être sous
les traits de la somptueuse angelina
jolie dans le film éponyme certains
d'entre vous pensent peut-être avec
nostalgie aux séries des années 2000
comme tchad où sabrina où les sorcières
sont de belles jeunes filles qui utilise
la magie noire dans un univers édulcoré
si l'on s'écarte un peu des films
certains d'entre vous ont peut être
pensé à la chasse aux sorcières du
maccarthysme aux états unis en pleine
lutte anticommuniste d'autres au
contraire plutôt vu de belles femme au
charme envoûtant ou complètement à
l'inversé certains d'entre vous ont
peut-être eu une pensée pour leur
vieille voisine inquiétante qui vit
recluse seule avec son chat bref quand
je vous dis sorcières c'est tout un
imaginaire qui se met en place chargé
des références de chacun en matière de
pop culture ou de littérature pourtant
quand je vous ai dit sorcière vous avez
sûrement été très très peu à penser à un
événement historique tragique et
pourtant de très grande ampleur c'est à
dire le sexo side des sorcières qui
durera près de deux siècles et pour
cause je ne vous jette pas la pierre moi
même il y a quelques années je n'avais
pas entendu parler ou ne serait-ce que
vaguement de ce 6e site des sorcières on
entend peut-être un peu parlé de la
chasse aux sorcières et on imagine tout
de suite le moyen âge l'âge sombre de
l'histoire européenne mais que nenni
contrairement à bien des idées reçues le
6 aussi des sorcières a eu lieu à l'aube
des temps modernes en pleine renaissance
européenne
du coup la chasse aux sorcières
expression un petit peu édulcorée compte
tenu des faits correspond à l'assassinât
de masse de femmes accusées de
sorcellerie dans toute l'europe allant
même jusqu'aux états unis protestants
entre 1450 et 1650
vous l'aurez compris dans cette vidéo
nous allons donc parler du 6 aussi des
sorcières le but c'est pour vous de
comprendre un petit peu mieux ce qu'il
en était perspective historique mais
également les implications sociales que
cela et pour ce faire je me suis appuyé
sur quatre ouvrages des sciences
sociales à ce sujet un essai de
françoise d'eaubonne qui s'intitule le
sexe aussi des sorcières qui paraît en
1999 un ouvrage très grand public qui
s'appelle sorcières de mona chollet une
somme très imposante de guy breschel qui
s'intitule la sorcière et l'occident et
enfin un essai majeur des études
féministes qui est qu'à liban et la
sorcière de sylvia federici voilà pour
les références nous allons passer à la
vidéo alors la première chose qu'on va
se demander c'est bien évidemment de
savoir qui sont les sorcières alors ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est que au
moyen-âge la sorcellerie correspond en
fait à l'herboristerie ou à celle qu'on
appelle lé physicienne c'est à dire des
femmes pour la plupart mais également
des hommes qui soigne avec les plantes
c'est donc un savoir anciens
traditionnels une fine connaissance de
la nature au service de la médecine qui
n'est pas encore entérinée de manière
rationnelle comme ça l'a été à partir du
15e ou 16e siècle mais peu à peu le sens
que l'on met derrière le mot sorcellerie
davy être sorcière ou être sorcier
revient à être un hérétique c'est à dire
une personne qui est contre la religion
catholique ou du moins contre eux la
bonne morale catholique et au fur et à
mesure que le mode et vit dans son sens
on remarque que la sorcellerie devient
un fait de plus en plus féminin en effet
de moins en moins d'hommes sont accusés
d'être des sorciers les sorcières sont
alors perçus comme des femmes qui
participent à tout un imaginaire
anticatholique avec par exemple les
messes noires ou le fait de pactiser
avec satan les sorcières sont également
accusés d'avoir une sexualité débordante
presque effrayante et du moins un
comportement qui va contre la morale
chrétienne ainsi le terme de sorcière
devient une manière de caractériser
péjorativement des femmes qui ont un
mode de vie des viandes par rapport à la
bonne morale chrétienne mais également
des femmes qui de manière générale
s'écarte du chemin qui était tracée pour
elle par exemple virginia woolf dans une
chambre à soi explique que les femmes
cultivées qui s'isole pour travailler
comme elles sont souvent accusés de
sorcellerie de manière générale l'image
nerf de la sorcière c'est une femme qui
mène une vie solitaire donc il n'est pas
marié qui a un âge plus tôt a avancé qui
vit dans une habitation et cartes et à
l'écart du village ou de la ville
souvent lisière de forêt par exemple
dans le film si belle on a vraiment
cette figure de la sorcière qui vit en
lisière de forêt dans un cabanon
totalement isolé du reste de la
communauté villageoise cela s'accompagne
d'ailleurs souvent dans l'aspect
physique singulier que ce soit par les
vêtements comme dans le film si belle
mais aussi par une particularité
physique soit une grande laideur soit
al'inverse une extrême beauté et c'est
là on retrouve la sorcière de blanche
neige et maléfique dans la belle au bois
dormant également dans les critères de
ce qui définit une sorcière on à la
compagnie d'un chat un animal qui est
considéré comme maudit et qui est
d'ailleurs fréquemment brûlé en place
publique à l'époque mais on a également
des traits de caractère qui sont censées
définir la sorcière par exemple une
mélancolie persistante qui pourrait
aujourd'hui peut-être est expliquée
comme les symptômes d'une dépression
font partie de l'imaginaire de la
sorcellerie et surtout à partir du 15e
siècle la sorcellerie est très nettement
affiné au milieu rural en effet il faut
se remettre dans l'idée que le mot
paysans vient de païens et donc que dans
le milieu rural il y à des coutumes des
traditions qui ne s'inscrit pas du tout
dans la tradition catholique ainsi la
célébration de culte anciens comme par
exemple avec les dents sous les chants
en groupe nocturne à l'extérieur sont
perçus comme clairement affiné à la
sorcellerie on le voit d'ailleurs dans
le film de céline sciamma le portrait de
la jeune fille en feu ou des femmes
issus du milieu rural se réunissent
autour d'un feu pour chanter des chants
traditionnels
c'est d'ailleurs quelque chose qui est
également évoquée par jeanne d'arc dans
son procès puisqu'elle se réfère aux
farandole de femmes autour de l'arbre
des faits par exemple cela partie
vraiment à l'imaginaire des sorcières
comme étant des femmes isolées qui se
réunissent pour célébrer des cultes
sombre dont on ne sait pas grand chose
et qui surtout s'écarte de la religion
catholique il ya également cette idée
des femmes magicienne des femmes qui
peuvent maîtriser les éléments et dans
une époque où la météorologie était
particulièrement déréglé où il ya eu de
grandes sécheresses puis des pluies
diluviennes et des famines qui ont
décimé de grande partie des populations
européennes
et bien cela faisait peur de se dire que
des femmes pouvaient affecter la
météorologie ainsi c'est d'ailleurs
quelque chose que l'on retrouve dans la
pièce de théâtre macbeth de shakespeare
ou de sorcières discute et propose de
s'offrir l'une l'autre un air de vent
bref vous l'aurez compris tout cet
imaginaire de la sorcière il est assez
diffus et en même temps il permet de
justifier que le féminin soit perçu
comme un danger imminent et universel
qu'il faut à tout prix détruire
maintenant qu'on a vu en détail quels
genres de femmes étaient ciblés par les
accusations de sorcellerie nous allons
parler plus en détails de la période qui
s'étend donc de 1450 et 1650 en europe
et aux états unis et qui est donc la
période du 6 au cid des sorcières alors
ce que françoise d'eaubonne a surnommé
le pieux sexo side c'est donc je lisais
étendu dans toute l'europe et jusqu'aux
états unis d'amérique ont peu après le
début de la colonisation sur une durée
de deux siècles donc 1450 et 1650
avant cette date il y avait déjà
quelques procès en sorcellerie mais qui
concernait autant les hommes que les
femmes et qui visait essentiellement ça
qu'on a fait les physiciens des
personnes qui pratiquent l herboristerie
par exemple des archives révèlent qu'en
1130 à toulouse 19 personnes ont été
brûlés sur place publique pour
sorcellerie et parmi ces personnes
seulement deux femmes donc la surfer dry
commencé à être vu comme une menace mais
c'est qu'à partir de 1450 que les
accusations de sorcellerie vise de
manière systématique et quasiment pour
l'essentiel uniquement des femmes à
partir de 1450 les archives montrent que
des femmes ont été brûlées massivement à
travers l'europe par exemple en quelques
mois dans la ville trèves plus de 7000
femmes ont été brûlés l'évêque de trêves
se vante d'ailleurs d'avoir brûlé tant
de femmes que les hommes natifs de la
ville doivent voyager très loin pour
pour trouver une épouse c'est d'ailleurs
des pratiques qu'on retrouve aujourd'hui
dans les pays où les avortements visant
spécifiquement les foetus de sexe
féminin sont encouragées je ne sais pas
si vous vous rendez compte mais le
nombre de femmes tuées à cette époque et
sans précédent c'est quelque chose qu'on
retrouve qu'à l'ère du fascisme au
milieu du xxème siècle ce sont donc des
assassinats de femmes qui sont
organisées par l'église c'est à dire que
le pape de l'époque 1908 a donné sa
bénédiction publiant une bulle à ce
sujet pour lancer le sexisme des
sorcières au nom de la lutte contre les
risques le terme d'hérétique à l'époque
c'est un petit peu ce que le terme
terroriste a pu être plus tard c'est à
dire un terme très vaste qui permet
d'englober des réalités différentes
et d'attaquer au nom de la lutte contre
l'hérésie des personnes très différentes
parmi les personnes qui ont organisé et
perpétré le 6 sociétés des sorcières on
retrouve donc des évêques comme l'évêque
de trêves que je mentionnais auparavant
mais également des procureurs on a par
exemple nicolas rémy procureur de
lorraine mais en 1530 mort en mai 112
qui aurait selon les archives envoyé au
bûcher plus de 3000 personnes dont une
écrasante majorité de femmes au nom de
la lutte contre la sorcellerie nicolas
rémy a d'ailleurs si p a institué la
doctrine du pacte satanique que
passerelle et sorcières avec son ouvrage
la démo nos la tri on a également un rib
aux gays dans le jura qui publie le
discours excécrable des sorciers qui
malgré son titre masculin parle en effet
plutôt des femmes et puis on a également
jean bodin une figure intellectuelle
phare de l'humanisme précurseur de
l'état de droit qui est pourtant un
ardent défenseur des crimes contre les
sorcières
donc vous l'aurez compris c'est bien le
pouvoir papal dont catholique et même
une alliance en fait avec les pouvoirs
politiques et juridiques qui ont
organisé les assassinats de masse qui
ont visé les femmes qui étaient dans la
cuisine de sorcellerie pour autant il
serait inexact historiquement de dire
que seuls les catholiques ont participé
a organisé le 6 au site des sorcières
puisque en effet le camp protestant est
aussi en partie responsables des
massacres des femmes lutter par exemple
a vigoureusement dénoncé la sorcellerie
et inciter au procès pour sorcellerie et
donc l'assassinât des femmes cela
donnait lieu à de très nombreux procès
du côté protestant notamment aux états
unis au tout début de la colonisation du
territoire nord américain
l'un des procès les plus célèbres c'est
le procès des sorcières de salem donc
c'est plusieurs personnes hommes et
femmes et donc majoritairement des
femmes qui ont été accusés jugés voire
tués lors de procès en sorcellerie
autour de la ville de salem dans le
massachusetts cependant si on va tout à
fait exact c'est aussi ce ces procès des
procès de salem qui ont mis un coup
d'arrêt au procès pour sorcellerie sur
le territoire nord américain puisqu'au
cours des procès il visait les sorcières
de salem le leader du clergé bostoniens
à l'époque a publié un texte dans lequel
il remet en cause le processus juridique
qui vise en fait à tuer ces femmes donc
dans ce texte s'intitule 4 conscience
sur les esprits maléfiques on a donc
cette idée qu'il apparaît comme
préférable de laisser s'échapper et
vivre dit sorcière plutôt que de
condamner de tuer un innocent donc c'est
ce texte qui met un coup d'arrêt aux six
au site des sorcières sur le territoire
nord américain
cependant en europe et notamment en
france ce n'est pas du tout pour des
raisons humanistes que c'est arrêter le
sexe aussi des sorcières en effet donc
au début du xviie siècle c'est à dire à
la cour de versailles sous louis xiv on
en est là je sais pas si vous vous
rendez compte mais au moment où louis
xiv était le roi soleil que les sciences
été développée qu'on était sûr temps
modernes en fait et bien en était encore
à faire des procès pour sorcellerie est
tué à grande échelle des femmes bref
donc à la cour de louis xiv plusieurs
femmes ont été accusés d'avoir consulté
une sorcière qui s'appelait la voisins
c'est l' affaire des poisons dont vous
avez peut-être entendu parler au même
moment on a également la montespan donc
l'une des favorites les plus exposés de
la cour qui est accusé de participer à
des l'histoire est donc face au scandale
puisque la sorcellerie toucherait même
les plus hautes sphères de l'état
colbert dans une forme de bon sens
ministériel décide de décrier la
sorcellerie de décrédibiliser les
pratiques des sorcières pour en fait
faire de la sorcellerie une imposture
plutôt qu'un crime et de cette manière
il va pouvoir protéger les plus hautes
sphères de l'état d'ailleurs peu après
l' affaire des poisons une pièce de
théâtre est commandée à thomas corneille
c'est la sorcière démasqué dans laquelle
les pratiques de sorcellerie sont
tournés en ridicule le but c'est donc
d'éviter un scandale dans les plus
hautes sphères de l'état et c'est ainsi
qu'on met fin de manière générale dans
toute la france et l'europe au procès
pour sorcellerie on a donc pendant deux
siècles soit si vous rendez compte mais
deux siècles c'est tout simplement
énorme des milliers de femmes qui sont
assassinés en europe et aux états unis
au nom de l'hérésie et donc la
sorcellerie dans une dynamique et une
logistique impulser et organisé par les
plus hautes sphères religieuses et
politiques voilà donc pour les faits
historiques concernant le sexe au site
des sorcières qui avait lieu sur près de
deux siècles
je ne boire un petit verre d'eau
au moins mauvaise
bon allez fais ma petite pause alors
vous l'aurez remarqué depuis le début de
la vidéo j'évite au maximum de parler de
la chasse aux sorcières je préfère
utiliser un autre mot qui est donc sexo
side alors le terme de sexo side a été
inventé par françoise d'eaubonne sur les
bases du terme de génocide
le bien au génocide et qui vient du grec
génos race et du latin side a tué est un
terme qui a été entérinée par l'onu en
1948 au lendemain de la shoah pour
désigner une série d'actes commis dans
l'intention de détruire tout ou partie
d'un groupe ethnique racial religieux ou
nationale donc hormis le meurtre pur et
dur des membres du groupe il ya une
liste d'actes qui qui participent au
génocide qui sont par exemple l'atteinte
grave à l'intégrité physique ou mentale
des personnes du groupe la soumission
intentionnelle
du groupe à des conditions d'existence
qui doivent entraîner la destruction
totale ou partielle du groupe mais
également toute mesure visant à entraver
les naissances et donc à ne pas
permettre la reproduction du groupe mais
encore tout ce qui concerne les
transferts forcés d'enfants donc
pourquoi françoise d'eaubonne elle
invente un mot qui part en fait de la
même logique que génocide elle remplace
donc la race génos par le sexe est donc
pourquoi est-ce que françoise degois ne
reprend cette idée de génocide pour
parler des meurtres des sorcières et
bien parce que selon elle toute cette
période a été marquée par une
organisation visant à encadrer les
meurtres commis contre une catégorie men
particulière c'est à dire les femmes
d'ailleurs françoise d'eaubonne elle
combat pour faire entrer le terme de
sexo side dans la langue française tout
comme auparavant elle a fait en train
autres mots dans la langue c'est le mot
de phallocrate qui n'existait pas avant
elle et qui désigne donc la domination
hégémonique des hommes sur les femmes et
donc les chercheurs spécialistes de la
question s'accordent pour dire que le
terme de sexo side est plus à même de
témoigner de l'organisation politique et
religieuse qu'il a fallu pour perpétrer
ces crimes de masse de femmes par
exemple sylvia federici rappelle bien
que le sexe aussi des sorcières n'est
pas le résultat d'un mouvement spontané
ou d'une forme de panique de la
population elle montre bien que les
assassinats de femmes résulte d'une
logistique organisationnel et
administratives et donc là encore on
peut faire le parallèle avec les
génocides tout comme locaux ce qui était
organisée par les pouvoirs en place mona
chollet dans sorcière fait le même
parallèle où elle explique que de la
même manière que dans le low cost on a
une dynamique qui est impulsée par les
plus hautes sphères pour mener en fait
c'est une accumulation des discours de
haine et à une forme en fait d'hostilité
dans la population qui en est rendu
presque obsessionnelle et qui permettent
aux pouvoirs en fait de légitimer et de
justifier le passage à la violence
physique qui alors est perçu comme
légitime pour défendre le corps social
en fait que les chercheurs et
chercheuses explique à ce sujet c'est
que concernant la shoah il ya eu de très
nombreuses recherches pour tenter
d'analyser et de comprendre comment
s'est formée cette mentalité qui au
final elle était prête à accepter la
réalité d'un massacre raciale les choses
qui nous paraissent totalement insensé
impensable depuis une autre position
actuelle or cette méthodologie a n'a pas
été appliquée au phénomène dit de la
chasse aux sorcières et qu'en fait de
personnes jusqu'à la fin du xxème siècle
n'a cherché à récapituler toutes les
politiques de dénigrement d' insulte
d'accusation permanente qui visait les
femmes au nom de la sorcellerie depuis
les origines du catholicisme en passant
par le moyen âge jusqu'à mener au
passage à l'acte avec la bulle
d'innocents 8 et l'appel au meurtre des
sorcières et donc des femmes ce
parallèle entre le sexe au site des
sorcières et le génocide des juifs les
chercheurs la mène un autre niveau et
l'analyse comme étant en fait tout un
processus qui a permis de fabriquer un
autre indésirable et dangereux alors
l'un des points communs qui honnêtement
un fait un peu froid dans le dos il est
mise en avant par françoise d'eaubonne
dans son essai le sait que ce site des
sorcières puisque elle fait un parallèle
en fait entre mein kampf donc le manuel
antisémite hitlérien et un ouvrage qu'on
appelle en français donc le marteau des
sorcières qui a été écrit par kramer et
springer au xvème siècle en fait ce que
dit françoise d'eaubonne c'est que ces
deux ouvrages appartiennent à
l'hallucinante possibilités humaines
déchaîné un massacre à partir d'un
raisonnement digne d'un aliéné en fait
c'est françoise d'eaubonne explique que
le marteau des sorcières qui est à
l'époque un best-seller agit comme un
guide qui explique comment en arriver à
l'extérieur à la détection et à
l'extermination des sorcières mais
également entretien cette obsession pour
l'élimination des sorcières et donc des
phares et cette méfiance généralisée du
coût envers les femmes d'ailleurs le
titre de l'ouvragé en atten mal et où ce
magnifique car on aurait dû être mailhos
ma fille corps ou mais dans ce cas là on
aurait plus dans une dimension des
sorciers et sorcières ici on dit
spécifiquement les femmes d'ailleurs les
auteurs le disent dans le livre les
sorciers sont bien peu de choses pour
signifier que c'est bien des femmes
qu'il faut se méfier quand on en arrive
à la sorcellerie selon françoise
d'eaubonne le marteau des sorcières tout
comme mein kampf là était est un ouvrage
qui incite clairement au meurtre d'une
catégorie particulière de la société en
la personne des femmes mais ce que dit
françoise d'eaubonne et qui est
extrêmement intéressant c'est que ce
texte donc le marteau des sorcières est
en contradiction avec l'évangile avec la
base le socle de la religion catholique
parce que en effet dans la région
catholique allemand tout péché et même
le péché originel peut être lavé par le
baptême or les femmes selon le marteau
des sorcières ne peuvent pas bénéficier
de cela bref au delà du parallèle entre
mein kampf et le marteau des sorcières
françoise d'eaubonne ainsi que les
autres otri ses auteurs qui ont
participé à la théorisation scientifique
de ce cycle haussier de des sorcières
font un parallèle entre juifs et
sorcières en ce qui concerne
l'imaginaire il faut se remettre en tête
c'est que à l'époque les juifs et les
sorcières était également perçu comme
étant des hérétiques les sorcières parce
qu'elles ont des pratiques déviantes qui
ne respectent pas la bonne morale
catholique et les juifs parce qu'ils
sont tout simplement accusé d'avoir
rendu possible le meurtre de jésus et
dont on a selon les chercheurs
spécialistes de la question tout un
imaginaire commun de l'hérétique qui
unit en fait les juifs et les sorcières
en témoigne le shabbat qui est donc le
jour de repos sacré des juifs mais qui
est également le nom donné aux messes
noires qu'elle se rend les sorcières
d'ailleurs on disait des sorcières qui
se rendaient à la messe noire qu'elle
allait à la synagogue ce parallèle entre
les juifs et les sorcières c'est quelque
chose qui est totalement verbaliser
accepté à l'époque au 14ème siècle on a
d'ailleurs un théologien espagnol alvaro
pelayo qui déclare que la femme est
semblable aux juifs d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant ici ne dit pas la sorcière
lui libère la femme et mona chollet met
en avant quelque chose d'assez
intéressant dans son essai c'est que qui
vous à la représentation des sorcières
et des juifs on a un imaginaire commun
là encore puisque on a souvent le nez
crochu qui est un attribut physique
totalement inventée en quelque sorte
mais qui serait le point commun pour
reconnaître un juif ou pour reconnaître
une sorcière met donc au delà du moment
le plus fort du sexe soucier des
sorcières la question que se posent les
chercher les chercheurs c'est de savoir
d'où vient la haine des femmes qui a pu
mener un tel massacre pour en arriver à
comprendre pourquoi l'occident chrétien
s'est acharné ainsi sur les femmes
jusqu'à souhaiter leur élimination
systématique
françoise d'eaubonne retourne aux
origines de la civilisation occidentale
et du coup aussi de la religion
catholique pour tenter d'expliquer les
origines de la haine des femmes alors
dans les évangiles et même selon les
pères de l'église
il ya quand même toujours cette idée
constante que la femme est un homme
diminué ce qui se traduit par de
nombreux interdits religieux concernant
la notamment la sexualité pourtant ce
que françoise d'eaubonne odyssée que
jésus donc jésus de nazareth défendent
est un message plutôt anti patriarcale
les théologiens les spécialistes de la
vie de jésus ont montré que de son
vivant il défend des un nouveau rapport
au sexe film sur une base d'égalité il
ya de très nombreux épisodes de la bible
qui montre sa main bref je pas revenir
en détail mais tout ça pour le dire
quand elle le sait que ce side des
sorcières a été perpétré au nom d'une
religion qui elle-même n'est pas
patriarcale à ses origines on a donc une
rupture complète et une inversion des
valeurs au sein de la religion
catholique qui permet d'en arriver au
massacre des femmes en face claude et
françoise d'eaubonne c'est que jésus de
nazareth est arrivé en rupture complète
avec la société fondamentalement
guerrière et masculine dans laquelle il
a vécu cette société masculine guerrière
elle trouve ses origines dans l'épopée
de gilgamesh en mésopotamie qui a
renversé la déesse ishtar qui incarnait
la fécondité la fertilité et le rapport
à la nature on a eu un premier
bouleversement dans les rapports de sexe
à ce moment là françoise d'eaubonne
estime que c'est aussi là le début du
patriarcat et elles montrent bien que
jésus arrive comme un personnage en
rupture complète avec les rapports de
sexe de son époque pour autant ce
qu'elle explique c'est que dès l'aube du
christianisme
on a un rejet des valeurs évangéliques
favorable au féminin avec par exemple
l'invisibilisation dans les évangiles 2
figure d'apôtres féminine hommes tabitha
par exemple qui est une apôtres reconnu
par l'acte des apôtres donc une app
autre femme mais qui est totalement
effacé des évangiles il en est allé de
même pour d'autres disciples de jésus
donc les historiens ont pu identifier
plusieurs disciples féminines par
exemple priscilla ou jus mias également
ce qu'a vécu dans la mise en récit de la
vie de jésus et donc aux origines du
christianisme c'est que le messie
finalement né d'une vierge et donc cela
sans fécondation masculine est montré
comme étant le fils d'un homme le rôle
de la religion n'est plus à prouver en
ce qui concerne le sceqe soucier des
sorcières cependant il y à d'autres
théories d'autres hypothèses quant à ce
qui aurait mené au défoulement une haine
du sexe féminin qui a poussé à insectes
société est l'une de ces hypothèses
c'est l'idée d'une rivalité
professionnelle alors quand je dérive a
été professionnel je parle bien d'une
réalité professionnelle entre hommes et
femmes en effet comme je vous le disais
au tout début de la vidéo pour 1 to le
moyen-âge les femmes ont la mainmise sur
la maîtrise de l'herboristerie la figure
de la physicienne et très respecté dans
les communautés et donc il ya un
véritable savoir faire des femmes en ce
qui concerne la médecine les dr s était
particulièrement respecté est nécessaire
puisque les moines avaient interdiction
de soigner les corps de femmes autres
figurants glas de la physicienne qui
était très respecté à l'époque c'était
celle de la mire est ce qu'ils se
trouvaient souvent sur les places dans
les villes de pèlerinage et qui était à
la fois une diseuse de bonne aventure
est une doctoresse sont à plusieurs
figures féminines très importantes de
l'époque qui ont été identifiés par les
historiens par exemple hildegarde de
bingen qui est une abaisse mais
également la compositrice et donc une
physicienne qui a rédigé un traité de
métier bref tout ça pour dire que dans
le moyen âge les femmes doctoresse donc
physicienne était particulièrement
respectée et reconnue puis on a
plusieurs éléments qui viennent
compliquer l'existence des femmes
doctoresse d'abord on à charlemagne qui
met fin à la puissance et à l'autonomie
des monastères féminin qui deviennent en
fait de petites principautés en dehors
du contrôle de la monarchie et ensuite
on à charles 8 qui interdit aux femmes
l'exercice de la profession médicale en
effet à ce moment là on a le
développement de la faculté et notamment
des facultés de médecine or ses facultés
à sont réservés à une stricte élite
masculine et aux dates salé faculté
d'accepter même que les hommes
célibataires puisque les hommes mariés
ont touché les femmes et donc on a un
champ de la médecine qui se rétrécit
très nettement les femmes n'ont plus le
droit d'exercer les moines ne sont pas
allés à la faculté et dans tous les cas
ils n'ont pas le droit de toucher les
femmes donc on a seulement des médecins
qui ont été à la faculté qui sont des
hommes célibataires non religieux qui
ont le droit de pratiquer la médecine le
champ de la médecine se rétrécit sort
aussi des campagnes on est sûrement dans
des élites plutôt urbaine et s'en suit
en fait aux essayé de nombreuses
épidémies qui ont ravagé l'europe et
donc dans la période on est en train de
rationaliser la science d'atteindre une
meilleure connaissance du corps humain
de développer la médecine on en fait
tout une fabrique de cette science
nouvelle et donc de cet homme nouveau
qui s'accompagne d'un véritable crime
contre les femmes d'ailleurs dans son
ouvrage gilberte elle dit bien que la
machine à fabriquer l'homme nouveau et
est aussi une machine à tuer les femmes
anciennes du coup comme le dit mona
chollet la médecine semble vraiment
avoir été la scène centrale sur laquelle
s'est jouée la guerre de la science
moderne masculine contre les femmes et
enfin la troisième hypothèse c'est aussi
que dans un moment de grandes
transformations socio-économiques et
bien le fait de perpétrer un c'est que
ce side des femmes donc d'entretenir la
haine des femmes a permis de transformer
les rapports sociaux et notamment les
rapports de travail c'est l'hypothèse
que défense il vient federici d'en-cas
liban et la sorcière la thèse principale
de ces via federici dans ce livre c'est
de dire que la chasse aux sorcières donc
le sexe au site des sorcières a permis
de préparer la division sexuelle du
travail qui était requise par le
capitalisme du début en fait la période
industrielle et donc ce que si la fédé
reach et explique c'est que et ne
s'agissait pas simplement d'exploiter
les femmes sexuellement et
économiquement qu'il s'agissait aussi de
chercher à les contrôler ont jamais
relâcher la surveillance avec du coup la
crainte d'être accusés de sorcellerie et
donc cela en allant jusqu à les éliminer
les supprimer purement et simplement que
nos dissidia federici sait aussi que le
6 au site des sorcières donc le fait de
tuer des femmes n'est que finalement la
monstruosité la plus voyante de cette
époque qui en fait se voit se développer
de manière plus générale une une forme
d'offensive globale contre les femmes et
du coup elle estime que c'est à partir
du sceqe soucier des sorcières que se
développe ce stéréotype de la femme
faible de corps et d'esprit et du coût
inférieur à l'homme une femme qui serait
du coup biologiquement sujettes au mal
au mal mani07 c'est le développement de
ces stéréotypes de la femme qui pourrait
facilement tomber dans le péché et qui
en plus est faible dans l'esprit dans le
corps qui justifie la prise de contrôle
des hommes sur les femmes dans tous les
domaines du coup c'est cela qui selon
ses affinités qui aboutit au nouvel
ordre patriarcal alors voilà pour
l'essentiel des informations que je
voulais vous partager au sujet du sexe
au site des sorcières je voulais
terminer cette vidéo en évoquant le fait
que certaines branches du mouvement
féministe contemporain se sont
réappropriés la figure de la sorcière
dans les luttes on a par exemple les
femmes donc sorcière du mouvement
women's lib donc aux états unis ce sont
des femmes qui dans les années 70 ont
manifesté en s'habillant donc dans
l'imaginaire de la sorcière avec des
chapeaux pointus et des bas l'ex terra
qui ont semé la pagaille à wall street
jusqu'au point de faire chuter la bourse
pendant quelques jours donc en france le
terme de sorcières il n'a pas été
vraiment revendiquée par les féministes
notamment du mlf donc du mouvement de
libération des femmes qui étaient actifs
à la même époque d'ailleurs petite
parenthèse mais je vous invite à aller
regarder ma vidéo à ce sujet si vous
n'avez pas encore vu si les féministes
françaises ne sont pas réapproprier le
mot sorcières c est ce qu en français il
a eu un sens de plus en plus édulcorée
notamment du fait des représentations
au cinéma dans les séries etc et que aux
états unis dans l'anglais américain il
ya quand même beaucoup plus ce sens
d'injures et presque d' insulte quand on
dit à une femme qu'elle est une sorcière
aujourd'hui a quand même de plus en plus
de féministes qui se revendique de la
sorcellerie notamment qui cherchent à
théoriser les liens particuliers qu'ont
les femmes avec la terre avec l'univers
en se réappropriant tout cet imaginaire
là qui nous vient tout droit de la patte
du grand rex aussi de des sorcières
voilà j'espère que cette vidéo vous a
plu c'est un sujet qui est évidemment
pas simple à traiter puisque on parle
quand même de l'assassinât massif de
milliers de femmes donc j'espère que ça
vous aura intéressé que ça vous aura
permis d'en savoir plus sur cette
période est également surtout
l'imaginaire de la sorcière aujourd'hui
c'était pour moi très important de
partager une vidéo à ce sujet avec vous
parce que c'est quand même fou de
réaliser que le cqcd sorcières est en
fait tout simplement effacé de
l'histoire on entend un petit peu parlé
mais sans plus alors que c'est quand
même en fait majeur des temps modernes
dans notre civilisation européenne c'est
quand même pas si loin de nous et on
n'en parle pas ou du monde en parle mal
donc j'espère que cette vidéo aura
contribué et bien à rétablir un petit
peu de vérité à ce sujet voilà je vous
invite de manière générale à vous
questionner quand vous êtes en cinéma ou
que regarder de série qui a des
sorcières vous questionnez surtout cet
imaginaire de la femme sorcières et puis
là j'ai hâte de vous lire en commentaire
de savoir ce que vous en pensez si vous
avez aussi des références à des
sorcières que je ne connais pas ou que
je n'ai pas évoqué dans cette vidéo
voilà en tout cas je vous remercie de
m'avoir regarder jusqu'à présent j'en
profite aussi pour vous remercier
puisqu'on a dépassé le minier d'abonnés
sur sociaux logos paraît totalement
irréel de me dire que vous n'êtes plus
de 1000 personnes à me suivre sur cette
chaîne ça fait tout juste un an que j'ai
lancé sociaux logos et j'aurais jamais
pensé touché une telle audience est
entré dans vos écrans donc merci encore
de me suivre si vous n'êtes pas abonné
je vous invite à le faire en cliquant
juste en dessous la vidéo et puis et
bien n'hésitez pas à laisser un gem a
laissé un commentaire à partager cette
vidéo et à faire vivre sociologue hausse
vous pouvez également monsieur sur
instagram où je partage davantage mon
quotidien de doctorante en sociologie
un grand merci à vous j'ai hâte de vous
retrouver je vous dis donc à bientôt sur
sociaux logos
[Musique]